as this monetary policy report went to
press
sterling oil prices were almost 90
percent above their levels at the end of
2020.
uk wholesale gas prices were almost 400
percent higher
wholesale electricity prices had risen
by more than 300 percent
the uk is a net importer of energy and
tradable goods
and the rise in global prices will
inevitably both put upward pressure on
inflation
and weigh on uk real income and spending
beyond the near term and conditioned on
a market implied path for bank rates
that rises to around one and a half
percent by the middle of next year
uk gdp growth is expected to slow to
subdued rates
a small margin of spare capacity is
likely to emerge later this year
and then to build over the forecast
period
turning to inflation uk consumer price
inflation raised to five point four
percent in december
well above its two percent target
and almost one percentage point higher
than expected at the time of the
november monetary policy report
most of the overshoot inflation relative
to the target
continues to reflect the more general
rise in the price of globally traded
goods
higher energy prices explain nearly one
percentage point of the rise in
inflation since september
but rising domestic cost pressures
driven by a tight labor market have also
added to the upward pressure on consumer
prices
albeit to a lesser extent
core inflation which strips out energy
and other volatile items
picked up to 4.2 percent in december
inflation is expected to increase
further in the coming months peaking at
around seven and a quarter percent in
april when higher utility price caps are
due to be implemented
in the central projection the upward
pressure on cpi inflation dissipates
over time
however as global energy prices stop
rising
and global supply constraints stabilize
while domestic cost pressures ease with
demand weakening
the widening degree of spare capacity
adds further to the downward pressure on
inflation in the second half of the
forecast
conditional on the market implied path
for bank rate
consumer price inflation is projected to
fall to a little above the two percent
target in two years time
and below the target by a greater margin
in three years